at the heart of this case is a chatty
nosey little girl
who her family say was nine
going on 19.
in their first statement they said liv
was adored by everyone who knew her and
would instantly make friends with anyone
and everyone
she was often seen going up and down the
street on her new bike she'd just got
for her birthday
although her life was short her
personality certainly wasn't and she
lived it to the most she could and would
blow people away with her wit and
kindness
we as a family are heartbroken and have
lost a huge part of our life
if anyone knows anything
now is the time to speak up
it is not about being a snitch or a
grass
it is about finding who took our baby
away from us
please
do the right thing
her mum cheryl is now out of hospital
and is being supported by the police who
have started one of their biggest ever
manhunts
after the shooting here at the top of
the screen on a neighbour's cctv we see
a flash of feet running away from the
scene
detectives have only been able to say
that he was dressed in black with a
balaclava five foot seven inches tall
and slim build
they have been given names but still
don't have their prime suspect
my message to him remains the same
we will not rest until we find you
and we will find you
how confident are you that he is still
in this city or still in the northwest
of england
it doesn't really matter to me we will
find him wherever he goes we have proved
that time and time again within multiple
inquiries could he be out of the country
then it's unclear at this stage i can't
comment any further
information is still flowing into them
progress they say is being made in this
and the two other fatal shootings that
merseyside police are investigating
but it's never as fast as everyone would
like
it takes time and patience to build
these kinds of cases but ultimately it
will count for very little if they can't
find the gunman who killed olivia
the requests for help are echoing around
the city
our entire community needs to come
together
if you know anything or have any
information on the incident please let
the authorities know
keeping quiet is not an option enough is
enough
quite simply olivia's family need
answers for them
doing what's right
could mean everything
tom parmenter sky news liverpool